so you've never used arcad in your life
and you've decided it's time to learn
well today's video I'm going to show you
exactly that what's going on guys my
name is David tomich I'm a registered
architect here in Western Australia and
today I'm going to walk you through the
absolute beginner level steps of arcade
26. if you've just downloaded the
software or have never ever used it in
your life today's video is for you after
this video you should have all the
skills you need to go and follow along
any of my tutorials and replicate a
small house or anything in between so
enough talk let's turn around to the
screen and get started with today's
tutorial so we're going to start by
opening rcad 26 and loading any template
available to you it doesn't matter what
template you have available because
basically as you work through arcad
you're going to eventually make it your
own what you're going to see is
basically one main workspace in the
middle then you're going to see a series
of toolbars around the edges so we're
going to start with some of the absolute
Basics first of all the toolbar on the
left hand side is your main working area
the toolbar up the top is going to allow
you to change edit and manipulate all of
your settings as you say fit and toolbar
on the right hand side is basically all
your story settings your sheet settings
your pages and your layout so if we're
to start with the left hand side panel
what you're going to see is basically
everything you need to create model and
document you can drag the side panel all
the way in and out to adjust it to how
you like it so if we want to drag it to
just icons we can drag it quite small
that way you have more of a working
space or you can increase it at the
start because you're most likely
unfamiliar with what the icons are so
you can see the text if you want to
continue dragging it out you can have a
two layer system but personally you're
most likely going to have it like this
to start off with if you don't like the
positioning of any of these toolbars you
can select the little arrow in the top
Let It Go and drag it out then you can
basically drag drop and reposition it
anywhere in the actual workspace how you
like it for me I like to leave it on the
left hand side and I like to leave it
extended all the way out from a basic
point of view there are a couple
toolbars that I personally think are
missing from the default in archicad so
what we need to do is come up to window
up the top scroll down to toolbars and
palettes is where you're going to find
all the extra little options and bits
and pieces basically toolbars is
everything up the top so if you scroll
through this list and activate them one
by one a new toolbar will appear
eventually you're going to find more and
more of these toolbars that are useful
so for example this toolbar most of the
primary functions that are actually
quite useful are already activated so
like the ax tool is already activated on
the main toolbar so we can close that
one off we don't need it but back to
window down to pallets and what I want
to activate is my renovation and my
Trace reference so let's turn on Trace
reference repeat that same step and turn
on renovation they should appear in the
top right hand side line and the bottom
right hand side of your Navigator if
they don't and they just randomly drop
in like they have before simply drag
drop wait to that highlighted space
appears and let go and they'll be
dropped in the trace and reference does
exactly that it references flaws and
stories and elevations so all you need
to do is right click on a story go show
as Trace reference and it will show you
whatever you've drawn on that floor
overlaid you can toggle that on and off
by simply pressing this button here and
you can also adjust which levels you
want to see from that so as an example
if I was to go ahead double click on my
ground floor plan draw a random shape of
walls escape double click on my first
floor and then right click ground floor
showers Trace reference you would see
those walls created underneath now if
you don't like the yellow color for
whatever reason you can select the
reference color and change it and you
can also change the activity color these
sliders basically indicate the opacity
of the underlay so if you wish to adjust
that you can as well for me I'm happy
with the yellow underlay I don't really
mind what the Android looks like so
double clicking back onto our ground
floor plan let's delete those Walls by
simply highlighting and deleting what
you'll notice is that I've just deleted
those walls but I'm showing the ground
floor as an underlay so they're still
appearing until I click and hold my
scroll wheel move across a little bit
then they'll disappear it's a weird
little feature of archicad it is useful
sometimes but it is something to take
note of nothing's wrong you just need to
move the screen around a little bit to
navigate through a floor planner
elevation you use the scroll wheel quite
a lot so I highly recommend a mouse with
a scroll wheel the Magic Mouse might be
great for Apple but it is absolutely
garbage for archicad so what you can do
in the main window is scroll in and out
to basically zoom in and out and then
click and hold the scroll wheel to pan
across they are two of your most primary
functions in this entire window space
and you'll use them non-stop right click
same as everything thing else opens a
right click one left click activates the
selection tool and unclicks by default
you'll also see four elevations set up
on your window each elevation basically
points around as it does in every other
program if we were to select one of
these elevations we can come up to the
top and see that our toolbar changes so
tapping Escape that will undo our
selection selecting that elevation
marker again things change up the top
left the same happens if we click on
wall simply draw a wall click on it the
wall changes as well so let's delete
that and slowly start working our way
through some of these elements so one of
the main things you want to do in arcade
is actually start drawing walls roofs
things like that it's incredibly simple
in arcad to do anything in 3D so let's
click on one of these walls up the top
you'll see everything change the first
most important feature is this layers
section archicad is designed around the
layer system very similar to photoshop
so you want to basically make sure that
everything that you draw is in the
correct layout if you don't know what
layer it goes into eventually you'll
figure it out because as you move
through your pages and your paper spaces
you don't want some things to appear you
do want some things to appear so for
example on your site plan you might not
want to show all the internal walls but
you do want to show them on your ground
floor plan so you'd make sure that all
of your internal walls are on non-load
bearing structure or an internal wall
layer that you can turn off into the
site plan next at the top you're going
to have how you draw your actual wall
types if you click and hold on any of
these shapes it's going to give you
different options so for example a
single wall a polygonal wall and two
different types of rectangles you also
have a couple different options if you
need and then you have your reference
line so your reference line is basically
at which point of the wall you want to
be drawing in you can draw from the core
outside core middle core inside or all
of the outside faces as well this is a
bit more of an advanced user technique
but typically what you want to be using
is either the core outside line or the
court inside walls for this we'll just
go core outside moving along we have our
structure at the top which if we click
onto it archicad automatically creates a
series of different wall types so it's
now broken up into folders rather than
just an abundance of different wall
types like it used to be in the past so
we can click on interior we can see a
number of different interior style walls
click on exterior a number of exterior
style walls you can go ahead and create
your own Composites your own wall types
but again that is more of an advanced
technique which we won't go into today
for this let's simply go to exterior
let's click on a 100 millimeter block
insulated cavity plasterboard wall and
then we can also see our linked stories
bottom and top now our link stories can
be adjusted through our story settings
that way if we ever adjust our story it
automatically adjusts or we can
completely define our Wall height by
going not linked and then superseding
this number so if we don't want it to be
three meters tall we only want it to be
2 7 we can simply type that in without
going into our story settings it is
ideal if you can keep them linked to
something that way you don't have to
worry about how walls move and change it
is automatically done for you but once
you've basically gone through some of
those quick settings and it is something
that eventually you just glance at you
know exactly what you need to change and
move on you can then start drawing your
first wall so to draw the First wall
you've selected your wall you've
pinpointed everything you want at the
top you click once and your first wall
begins to be drawn you can basically
draw the wall in any direction you want
however if you hold shift it is going to
draw a dead straight wall in basically
any 90 degree formation so holding shift
straight up and down we can either try
and perfectly pinpoint exactly the
distance we want or we can tap the D
button for David which indicates the
distance and then simply type in a
number and press enter so as you saw we
typed in 5000 it created a five meter
long wall and then I can repeat that
same step D let's go ten thousand long
hold down the shift button again you'll
see that our guides are activated so we
can simply go all the way across return
to our original starting point where our
little Hammer icon appears press the
left button once again and it will
automatically create those walls now
because arcad is a 3D Bim modeling
software what we can do is simply right
click show all in 3D if you're new to
arcad then you might want to check out
one of these desk mats the desk mat is
available from the link Down Below in
the description box and basically it
contains all the required shortcuts you
need to know to master archicad now the
desk mat is available in three different
colors for PC and Mac so if you do want
to grab yourself one check out
xavatummage.com it will be the first
link in the description box down below
we have our first walls created
automatically but what you'll notice is
they're created the wrong way around so
our plasterboard is actually meant to be
on the inside and a brick is meant to be
on the out side you can go ahead and
easily redraw this entire shape or you
can simply tap the P button for Peter
and it will flip them automatically for
you now that we've activated our 3D
layer you see that some of our icons up
the top have changed so we have our view
window for our ground floor a view
window for our 3D and our view window
for our South elevation if you don't
want to see one of those windows because
they do take up a little bit of memory
you can simply hit the x button and it
will close it it won't delete anything
it won't change anything and you can
refine it back in your navigator on the
right hand side unlike other 3D
softwares like Rhino and Revit you can't
have multiple windows open so you can
basically jump and work between them so
if you try to drag and drop your tabs
even if I double click on another
elevation try to open up a second one
it's not going to let you do it it will
allow you to reposition these tabs like
you do in a web browser but that is
about the extent of it if we come back
into our 3D window and look at our walls
let's say we don't like any of these
walls so I click on one of the walls and
automatically it selects all of them it
does that because when we were in our
ground floor plan clicked on wall we
selected our multi-wall selection if we
were to draw it as a single wall then it
wouldn't group them automatically
however that doesn't mean that's a
problem at all it basically saves you
time later down the track if we press
Escape press option or alt and the G
button for good it will ungroup that
selection so now you can simply click on
just one wall or by holding the shift
button you can select multiple to
reactivate the grouping you just press
option G again and click and it will
automatically group something if you
only want to group two elements for
example you would select both of them by
holding shift and clicking and then
pressing the command or Control G button
to just group those two elements so now
when I click on my walls in an activated
group then it will only select two of
them I can again select all four Control
G command G and it will regroup them
entirely I have having things grouped it
allows you to change all of their
settings at once we can go and
individually change every single wall
setting or we can select Everything at
Once come up to the top where we see our
little icon for settings or press
command T to open up those settings now
the settings tab in arcade is something
that you'll go through every single day
and every single minute it is by far one
of the most useful features in archicad
because it lets you do whatever you want
completely free so for example we're
basically replicating that whole top
section of what I showed you before we
have our link story settings we have our
wall type in case we want to change it
we have exactly the reference layers
projection from zero the ground story
and all of our basic structured
information about that wall down below
we have our floor and section view
settings so it'll basically show us how
it will represent this wall in 2D and 3D
if for whatever reason you want to
override the surfaces you can do that by
creating a new wall structure or you can
simply activate one of these overrides
so if for example the studco white rough
and change it to a different color so
let's say I want it to be beige instead
of white press OK all of my walls are
automatically changed to beige without
me having to do too much work now like I
mentioned before these walls are linked
to our stories so if I press Ctrl or
command 7 that will open up my story
settings as you can see I only have a
ground floor plan and then one two and
nothing below so if I wanted to I could
simply insert something below call that
footings change number one to ground
ceiling and then change number two to
second floor introduce another layer
above and call that roof here I can
adjust the heights of everything between
our floors so as an example 172 for our
footings three meters to our next story
our ceiling space probably only needs to
be 300 a second floor can be three
meters and our roof probably only needs
to be about 600 mL and then I can go
ahead and press OK what you'll see if we
click on the view map you're going to
see that it's automatically changed our
floor plan names and introduced new
elements so if we double click it'll
take us to our ground floor second floor
and so on if we go back and press
command 7 again and for whatever reason
our ground floor has now jumped to five
meters because our walls are linked we
can press enter and all our walls will
automatically jump up instead of having
to go through and update all of our
walls one by one it has done it
perfectly for us if we come back to our
ground floor plan and say we want to
introduce some windows or some doors we
simply hit that door button and we can
very quickly without even worrying about
any of the settings click drag drop and
we have our first door obviously this
door isn't correct it isn't modeled
correctly it is just indicative because
with a cavity wall you obviously want to
close off the cavity and I have no idea
what the door looks like so if I select
that wall command T to open up my
settings again you're going to get the
door settings the door settings the
window settings the object settings
they're all very much the same and they
have the same principle layout up the
top you have your four viewpoints so you
can see the door and a floor plan an
elevation and 3D and also a rendered
view the most important are basically
these three squares at the top because
it lets you showcase how you see that
model in floor plan elevation and 3D so
as a 3D model you can see it is a timber
frame door glass section in the middle
and it is a swing door if we don't want
that leaf to look like that simply click
on Leaf pick one of the hundreds of
styles available to us and change it it
will automatically change that door for
you perfectly if you want to add a
handle click on the handle click the
handle and it will activate something
you can then slowly work your way
through all of these settings changing
the door as you see fit and to your
perfect liking there are a lot of
settings in archicad so that's why
people will go ahead and create their
own favorites create their own templates
create their own libraries and you do do
that eventually over time as you're
creating things specifically for jobs
you don't have to go ahead and just
spend days and weeks and weeks just
updating libraries and creating elements
if we come across to our model
attributes this is how we change the
actual material for the objects now we
can simply click on black for the leaf
and frame and all of our leaf and frame
settings will change if we select the
main drop down menu we can come back in
down to the bottom to our other model
attributes and change that to black as
well so now we have a fully black door
introduced into our space and if we
wanted to close off this reveal we can
go reveal to face and change that to 90
mil that simply just closes off that
cavity and we can check it out in 3D
that door has been created fully in 3D
completely custom and just orange so
personally I don't like the orange so
command T we can either go through all
of these 2D settings change all the
orange or I can simply select the
planned view come down or override my
model attributes and change that to
black gray whatever color I want press
OK escape and our orange is completely
gone so if you come back to our ground
floor plan now zoom out a little bit
you'll see that our door has been
created on our North elevation we
basically pressed a couple buttons to
draw some walls and some doors and if I
was to double click on my North
elevation in my view map you'd see
exactly that the walls with our door
created now you notice the story
settings on the right and the left
you'll also notice these gray bars
basically the gray bars if we come back
to floor plan are the extent of our
elevation markers if we click on an edge
and extend that a little bit further
come back into our North elevation
you'll see that gray bar jump across now
that's just a visual representation it's
not going to be there when you export
however if you don't like seeing this
gray space simply right click and untick
elevation range and that will all
disappear again if you don't like these
settings you can go back into our story
settings by pressing command 7 untick
those boxes press OK and they will also
disappear the way archicad presents its
elevations is completely up to you and
it's very simple to change so double
clicking back on our ground floor plan
let's highlight this North elevation and
open up the settings we can basically
adjust our settings by working through
this model appearance to however we see
fit so anything uncut so basically
everything you see in an elevation at
the moment is going to be a solid shaded
color it's going to have no texture it's
going to have no detail it's not going
to have much but if we change this to a
textured feel shaded press OK jump back
into our North elevation you'll see that
we see that brick work we see that
hatching we actually see the value and
the detail this might not be required
for everything so we can come back in
again change our settings then you'll
see we've lost all that texture we've
lost all that Clarity we've just got a
very simple boxed image now these
settings completely up to you how you're
documenting how you draw boring but the
options are there and the options are
endless the rest in our CAD is very much
the same so if we were to draw a slab we
can come down to our footings right
click our Trace reference and simply
draw a slab underneath our brickwork
coming back into 3D you'll see our slab
exists it's not set in the right place
it's the not the right material that
we're wanting maybe we want to concrete
with 10 mil tile and then we might want
to actually increase the height of that
as well so we can select our slab click
on any one of these hot spots you'll get
another little toolbar activate we can
select any of these depending on what we
need so if we click hover and let go
it's going to show you what each
individual item is so do it if I want to
offset all edges I can select that but
for the purpose of this I just want to
drag so I'm going to click this little
object drag it up a little bit escape
and there we go now we have our slab we
can jump back into the ground floor plan
click on our roof we can either select a
single pane or full geometry roof and
simply just click drag click again draw
a roof come back into 3D and we have a
very large excessive roof drawn we can
click that roof change our settings to
20 degrees change our settings 25
degrees do whatever we like to create
what we're looking for just like
everything else in our card you can
select the objects command C to open up
the settings go through everything
change the materials let's say we want
it to be gray press OK and there we go
we have a gray shingled roof now let's
say for whatever reason you've completed
everything you need to you're ready to
export this drawing out but you have no
idea how well that's when we move across
to our layout book our layout book is
the last little object on the right hand
side if this palette doesn't appear for
whatever reason window palettes and
Navigator needs to be turned on by
default our cat will give you a series
of pages so if you double click you're
going to see automatically set up your
ground floor your stories and your
elevations I can simply go into them and
it will show me what I've created what I
have done is actually cut off quite a
bit of that house so if I select that
elevation select one of the edges drag
up extend this out to wherever I need it
to be it will automatically update and
adjust for me if I jump back to the
ground floor plan and let's say this
didn't exist so let's delete the ground
floor plan and I just had a blank page I
could then come back into my navigator
click drag and drop my ground floor plan
into the papers layout space and it
would be exactly there just like in
elevations if I didn't want to see any
extra bits and pieces I could adjust
that external square that basically Cuts
everything out and shows you only what
you want if you wanted to change the
title bar at the bottom you would simply
activate the settings go through the
settings adjust what you see fit and
change that title bar let's say we want
it to be black instead of blue press OK
it is all changed for us the page
layouts themselves are all defined in
our Master layout settings so if I right
click this page go to layout settings
I'll see this is an A2 landscape Master
paper space I can drop that down to A4
press OK and it will automatically
change the page for me in this master
down the bottom let's double click on to
the A4 portrait zoom in and we can see
all of our custom details now these
details are all automatic you can see by
the hashtags before and after the text
so if we come into file info project
info it's going to open up our project
info pad here we can add information
that automatically gets updated into our
title block so for example project name
project address if I simply type in
YouTube tutorial press OK you'll see the
project name automatically change and be
updated so once again file info project
info we can go through all of these
step-by-step add all of our details
information press OK and all of our
pages will automatically be updated now
you're probably ready to export some
pages because you've dragged and dropped
everything you need you've set up your
pages and it's all good to go so the
easiest way and my personal favorite is
to click the three little lines on the
right hand side go to show organizer and
it'll open up another palette now this
organizer tool is identical to all of
these at the top and if you wanted to
adjust any of these views you can drag
and drop and adjust what I want to do is
come to my layout book and then create a
new folder I want to create this as a
YouTube
tutorial press OK and then I'm going to
select our layout maybe I just only want
to export my ground floor plan and my
North elevation I don't want to export
everything I only want those two pages
for whatever reason I can then right
click publishing properties browse to
local file system and then save that
wherever I want on my desktop once I've
defined a path I can come out of that I
can either Define to merge as one PDF or
export as individual pages so for
example I just click merged PDF and then
all you have to do is press the publish
button it will go ahead and publish
everything in this publisher so I can
simply just delete that layout keep that
one there select it hit publish and we
are 100 completed anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you learned archicad 26
I hope you feel a lot more comfortable
if you like to follow along any other
arcad tutorials take a look at the
playlist to the side of me if you love
the video I'd appreciate it if you smash
that like button and the Subscribe
button but that is all for me so I'll
see you next Monday